hello and welcome to this talk
thanks for your your interest i will be
talking about an
oven time algorithm for finding hamilton
cycles with high probability
my name is pascal i'm from eth zurich
and this was joint work with raikkonen
adolf and angelico
so i will be using standard graph
terminology
just for completeness let's see a
hamilton cycle
hamilton cycle is a walk on the edges of
the graph
such that we visit every vertex exactly
once and we return to the
original vertex the starting vertex
finding hamilton cycle is a well-known
problem in computer science and
mathematics
and determining whether one exists is
np-hard most of the community does not
believe that there exists a polynemicing
algorithm
to find to find
a hamilton cycle or even to determine
whether one exists in a graph
so in general this is a hard problem and
we
do not expect to find a polynomial time
algorithm
but already very early the electronic
theorem which said that if every vertex
has degree at least n over two
so the min degree is n over two then
the graph must be hamiltonian
and the way that one way to prove
diglock's theorem
is to use positive rotations and poser
rotations are a
very common tool in this area um
very many proofs rely on the fact that
we can
rotate a pass and then try to extend it
to a hamilton cycle the way this works
is
if we have a pass of some length and
um we would like to extend this path so
we would like to make it longer
but it could be that the end point of
the pass no longer has any
free edges to uh on the to
unused vertices then we can take an
edge from this end point to any vertex
along the path
like this and we can replace the
procedure the proceeding edge of the
vertex with
the new edge and then we get a new path
which covers the same vertex set but we
now have a different endpoint of the
path
and we can hope that from this endpoint
we
find edges to new
vertices which are currently not in the
past
these polarizations can be repeated and
at some point we hope to find a
continuation of the path so that we can
extend it to more vertices
there are several different variations
of the poser rotations the one we will
be using in this talk
is the second one here we use two edges
and the advantage of this positive
rotation is that
the order of all the vertices stays the
same
so the the predecessor of every vertex
except for this one here and then vertex
are the same so in particular also if we
had directed
edges this would still be a valid
new path
all right so in this talk i would like
to talk mainly about
random graphs in random graphs we have
the random graph
model g and p which is most likely the
most well known and well studied random
graph that we know
and it describes the graph on n vertices
where every edge
is present with probability p between
zero and one
each edge is there independently and
if we take concentration bounds then
also using direction we immediately see
that
if p is slightly above one half this
graph must be hamiltonian with high
probability
because every vertex with high
probability has more
than n over two edges
the question is of course this is the
best possible
and um here i would like to extend
a bit on random graphs we of course know
the random graph
gnp but there also exists other random
graph models such as
g and m which is a uniform graph from
all
graphs with m edges or a g and r which
is a
our regular graph again chosen uniformly
from all
our regular graphs or a k
out which is a graph where we add
at every vertex edge chosen uniformly
k edges charges and uniformly at random
i'm deleting multi edges if we need a
simple graph
or for example sometimes we
want a property such as the mint degree
and for gnp
we can restrict on the minimum degree
being at least
l for all of these graph models we know
very precisely where the threshold for
hamiltonicity is
for g and p the threshold is around
log n over n and we know precisely
when the ten probability tends to zero
and when the probability turns to one
this threshold actually coincides with
the threshold for minimum degree of two
should be clear that any vertex with
degree one cannot be part of a hamilton
cycle
as any cycle any vertex in a cycle has
degree two the same holds for dnm
we know the threshold very precisely and
the threshold again
coincides with minimum degree 2 in the
graph
also for g and r um the regular random
graph we know that
three regular graphs are hamiltonian
with high probability
and two regular graphs are not with high
probability
um the same goes for k outs there again
three outs are hamiltonian two outs
are not and again the bottleneck is
uh is when three vertices share a
c vertices of degree two share a common
neighbor
um for conditioning on minimum degree
two
we have also the gnm and also gnp
have a threshold for hamiltonisity and
there are very similar results on
various
on various related problems of
hamiltonicity
random in random graphs we can find very
many
disjoint hamilton cycles as soon as
there exists at least one
we can pack hamilton cycles we can find
rainbow hamilton cycles
all these are well-known results and
illustrates that
on random graphs it is the problem of
determining whether there exists a
hamilton cycle is very different than
the general hamilton cycle problem
so this brings us to
our second part the algorithms
algorithms for random graphs have been
known
for a while and this is just an outtake
of a few
of them in already
in the year 79 ongoing and valiant
proposed an algorithm
with time n log squared um
which works for random the random g and
p
as long as we are a constant factor
above the threshold
later xiaomi and also bullerbus fender
and freeze improved the threshold for
which we could
determine the existence of hamilton
cycles down to
p being exactly the threshold and
there was less the focus on the runtime
this is why the run times here are n
squared and n to the four
but these are all polynomial times which
is
significant for the p versus np question
later there are results by gravitz
schiller thomason alone cleveland
which also showed some improvements
there
they actually use the adjacent adjacency
matrix model
and therefore their times are optimal
and they can show their results down to
a p
of one over square root n
okay so there will be a technical detail
in this talk
namely that we actually want an o of n
time algorithm but the number of edges
in our graphs
can be will be at least n times log n
if p is login over n so we are not
actually allowed to look at all of the
edges of the graph
so we assume that the adjacency lists
are randomly perturbed
and that we can query the next edge at
any vertex
constant time there are there is a
bit of a technical detail to prove that
we can also in constant time
query a neighbor such that this neighbor
is distributed uniformly at random
among all neighbors so
if we if you if you would like to see
the details on this
we would refer to lemon8 in our paper
so
so for a start i would like to explain
how the original
algorithm of angular and volume works
because our
algorithm works very similarly besides
that we
improve upon some of the steps so the
idea is
because in the random work we random
graph we have so many hamilton cycles
we can do a random walk type strategy
and
hope to succeed anyway so this means
that we can start an invertex
and then query an edge and as long as
the new vertex is not
in an unvisited vertex we add this edge
to the
rd the path we already have and
this works very well at the beginning we
can just add edges as
as long as there's a linear fraction of
vertices unvisited versus left
we can in constant time query new edges
such that we find a new edge
to an unvisited vertex
at some point when the pass is long
enough we expect
to find a lot of edges which
connect to vertices which are already
part of the path
if the distance of this this vertex
that we that we have an edge to is less
than n over 2
to the n vertex of the pass then we
throw away this edge
however if the distance is at least n
over two then we keep this edge
we and we replace the
preceding edge of that vertex
like this and we detach a cycle which
by definition will have the length at
least n over two
this way we get a new start a new
endpoint of our pass and from there we
can keep on querying
we keep on querying until
while we find new unvisited vertices and
if we ever hit a vertex of the cycle
again
we can reincorporate the cycle into the
pass by
deleting the proceeding edge of that
versus
vertex and then again
getting a new endpoint
in this way any endpoint is
with high probability is never end point
of the path for
long so we never query too many edges
from the same vertex
and the probability of hitting uh of
hitting the
and a new unvisited vertex is the same
as the coupon collector problem
so let us quickly analyze the runtime of
this algorithm
we want to we query random edges from
every vertex
and hope to find all unvisited vertices
this
is equivalent to the coupon collector
problem and
this will have runtime of n log n
there is an additional technical detail
that whenever we need to detach a cycle
and we incorporate it we will need to do
this pulsar rotation
which due to the nature of the data
structure of storing this and up
obtaining updating and maintaining the
data structure
this will cost an additional login
factor and because
towards the end of this algorithm we
will need to to pause our rotations
during a constant fraction of the steps
this log n factor really comes into play
and the total run time is then n log
squared
all right so we would like to improve on
this and the first step
is what that we do to is to avoid pulsar
rotations
and we do this by instead of trying to
be
trying to build a hamilton path we first
tried to build a perfect matching
and um the advantage of a perfect
matching is that
any change is only made locally so if
a vertex finds a neighbor which is
already in the matching
we can replace the edge with the
matching edge
and then continue from the newly
unmatched vertex
this way all changes are made locally
and we don't actually have to store in
the database
though anything any updates in the rest
of the matching
and in the second step we
will make the graph bipartite this is a
not this is not actually a necessary
step
but i believe it helps in the
visualization of how
it works
so if we run the same algorithm with
bipartisan a and b let's say we query
edges from vertices in b at the
beginning we expect to
often hit unmatched vertices in a and
whenever
we do so we add these edges to the
matching
we do this for a while as long as it
is fast enough and then we will see
if um if we hit from a vertex in b
we hit the already matched vertex in a
we can replace these edges
as discussed before and then
search query edges from the newly
unmatched vertex in b
and if we then hit an unmatched vertex
in a
we can simply replace the previously
matched edge
and in total increase the matching by
one
and so
we will call the unmatched vertices in a
the target set
this the size of this target set will be
important for the runtime of the
algorithm for any vertex in b
if we query an edge the probability that
we
hit a vertex which is unmatched is
exactly the size of this target set
divided by the total number of vertices
in a
which we will call n for now so the
probability of success after a single
step
is size of the target set divided by n
and of course if we
consider the random variable of
increasing the matching by one
the time it needs for this this will be
a geometric theory a geometrically
distributed variable
with expected length n divided by the
target set
and in particular when the target says
becomes very small
this will tend towards n which is quite
long if we want the
entire algorithm to run in o of n time
okay so to improve upon this we want to
increase the size of the target set
and how the way we do this is we expose
neighbors of the unmatched vertices
and add their matched
partners to the target set
so if we have a target set here we
choose an appropriate d and we expose
from every vertex here
d many neighbors into the set b
these neighbors again are queried such
that
the vertices are distributed uniformly
at random
so we can also expect the size of this
neighborhood
to be roughly of size d times the target
set as long as
the target set is small enough we will
call this the d
neighborhood so for any vertex now
in in b if we query the next edge
we will call it a success if we hit a
vertex in the target set
or if we hit a matched partner of a
vertex in the d neighborhood
since then we can simply take the edge
to this vertex
and the edge from the d neighborhood to
the target set
and increase the matching by one
as the picture makes clear this now
greatly improves
our probability of success if d is
uh large enough and especially when the
target set is small
let us analyze the front time for
different d's as we said before if d
is zero then we have the same situation
as before
and uh the collet and the expected
number of
exposed edges from b is exactly
equivalent to the coupon collector which
is n over log n
however if d is of that log n
then we always expect the target size to
be roughly
of of an order of log n larger
which also decreases the random walks um
by a factor of log n so we expect to
only need linear time
to find to increase all the
the matching to a perfect matching
however we should also consider that we
need to expose
edges from the target set so from every
vertex
and um of course if d is zero then we
need
do we do not need to expose any edges
however if d
is log n then the number of exposed
edges
becomes n log n and this actually
dominates
the runtime of the coupon collector and
therefore this is also not very useful
for what we have in mind so what we need
is to find
and the appropriate d such that both the
coupon collector and the edges revealed
become linear
and what we do here is we actually take
a d which varies as the target set gets
smaller
so if we say t is the size of the target
set which remains
then we choose d to be the minimum
of square root of n over t and log n
so as we see here at the beginning if t
is the entire set of a
then this term becomes 1. so we only
expose constantly many
neighbors of every vertex but
as deep as t becomes smaller so as
the targets that become smaller um this
will
become log n in the end namely as soon
as
t is n over
log squared
and now if we analyze this the coupon
collector
should take time the sum of t to
n n over dt which
if you we do the calculations we can
show that this is o of n
but also the number of exposed edges we
need will be the sum of the dts
which also if we do the calculations
this we will see this is
linear so in total we only need linear
time
all right so with this trick we were
able to show that we can
find a perfect matching in our random
graph in linear time
and what we do now is instead of
trying to increase the perfect matching
directly
we simply take two perfect matchings we
can
take two perfect matchings make them
independent
by forgetting the first perfect matching
during the algorithm
and then we get a two regular graph this
two regular graph
will maybe look like this we have we'll
have some red
edges some green edges and they will
build
cycles or double edges um
in the graph and of course our hope
would be
that these two perfect matching form a
hamilton cycle
or if not a hamilton cycle at least that
the number of cycles that they create
is not too large but in fact it's not so
difficult to show that
these two um perfect matchings because
they are independent
behave exactly like the cycles of a
permutation
and it's quite well known that the
expected number of cycles
in a permutation is that of log n and
this
is also concentrated with high
probability
so in the end we get after
taking two perfect matchings
log n many or avoided login many cycles
and then these cycles should be much
easier to join together
to form a hamilton cycle
we we apply the similar trick as before
we expose a neighborhood from from one
vertex of
every cycle um we expose logan many
neighbors
and then from the endpoint of a current
of the path we currently have we also
expose logan many
neighbors if we can find two adjacent
vertices which are
which are in these new neighborhoods
then we can form
a new a new path
which is illustrated in red here which
includes the cycle
and keeps most of this the path
structure
the same and if we do not we can simply
close or rotate the entire path and
retry with a new endpoint
so there's some technical details out
here how to store the paths and the
cycles in a way such that the testing
can be done into constant time
and the rotations can be done in login
time but
for this we can apply avl trees combined
with
linked lists and
if you're interested in further details
we would refer to level 10
of the paper thank you for your
attention
if you have any question feel free to
write an email
or ask during the talk